now that CS2 is out a lot of Pros are
coming out of retirement but what
comebacks would be the most hyp for
starters scream to this day he holds the
record for most head shot per round in
CSG go he's got one bullet in it he's
he's he's got one bullet oh scream next
up Stewie maybe it's just na copium but
Counterstrike is in young Stew's blood
and always will be I don't care how
poorly things went on EG despite having
both a major and a slam he's as hyper
competitive as ever and primed for a
comeback two more m one more dude they
don't know that I can be back just like
that lastly yampy having been forced to
leave Cs on account of a vac ban for
which he was genuinely not responsible
yamp quickly cemented himself as a
household name in EU valerant scenarios
it could be Ted to hold no scope from
yumy go both come on BR it's it's time
to come home